thank you doctor well I enjoy listening
to you on 70s with George Noory I'm good
love George we do I have my kids and I
were diagnosed with a double chromosome
the homelessness 15
it's the MTHFR c6 770 as far as I
understand it it's I'm having a hard
time absorbing folic acid and b12 so
it's like an enzyme deficiency but the
one that's mostly impacted is my 21 year
old daughter and she also was diagnosed
with the pair oral dermatitis and so she
has the double chromosome plus that and
she's having some pretty serious
flare-ups with her her throat swelling
or face swelling whenever she's in
contact with a steroid cream or dextrose
or story or gluten or oils and it's
really impacting her quality of life and
okay stop there yeah we got a handful
here right so how much you weigh what I
mostly want to address my daughter okay
well with all of them you have to if
we're gonna dress her we have to dress
you okay okay wonderful I am a size five
six and I weigh 115 okay and what is she
waiting I'm Thalia she she's five five
and she weighs 130 okay so about the
same all right
now do you have any skin problems we
have we break out around our mouth area
okay this really rosacea would it be
cold it's more like a blistery thing
okay yeah we used to call it impetigo
and it was a kid okay
alright and let's see here okay
Charmaine I'm here earth to duck okay
Debbie is about your weight and her
daughter's about 15 pounds heavier
and they have certain problems let me
ask one more question here Debian char
and I are going to give you something
get your pen and paper I'm do either you
or your kids have any history of asthma
or bronchitis yes so all the kids in you
yes
okay okay Charmaine what's the problem
here fire yeah they have a gluten
intolerance absolutely drop-dead gluten
intolerance and so what kind of diet
would you put them on obviously a
gluten-free diet yep
and no fried foods and processed meats
and oils and glutens right no wheat
bread around oats and then when when
people have a hard time absorbing b12
even feed five pounds of it you can't
absorb it
there is a cofactor called the intrinsic
factor that binds under the b12
it requires an acid environment to
actually help you absorb b12 so what
what enzyme supplement so we can
maximize the absorption of b12 the
ultimate ciliates without oh yeah yeah
the ultimate enzyme is very good it does
have stomach acid in it
your weight you can take one of those
say two minutes for each meal a couple
ounces of water that's going to help
acidify the stomach
you can also saw your food we have a
wonderful salt that goes along with with
our tea here is part of our herbal and
spice division okay so you can talk
about ask about our salt for the herbal
in spices
sodium chloride chloride is what the
chief cells use your stomach to create
stomach acid which acidifies the stomach
so the intrinsic factors work to absorb
b12 and what what supplement would you
add to all their diets charmaine to make
sure they're getting b12
I would have the ultimate vitamin d3
okay those Detra what about b12 oh I
would add the ultimate the destress
you got it there you got an a-plus yeah
destress go ahead and take three of
those twice a day there's two bottles a
month that would be three and breakfast
for you dinner time and then let's see
here
lastly I think that covers it oh the
folic acid if you want the folic acid
you really really want to
again take the healthy brain and hard
pack that one has folic acid in that's
going to do it and the liver is what
methylates the folic acid okay and so by
doing the healthy brain and heart pack
you're gonna give the liver everything
it needs to be happy and to methylate
the folic acid to maximize your
absorption give us a call this you you
and your whole family are gonna have to
do this because it's not a genetic thing
but you have passed the gluten
intolerance on to your family and the
doctors have missed this one by a
thousand miles okay so each you and your
kids and particularly the girls because
they will pass it on to their children
it's not a genetic thing but it is
generational because of the gluten
intolerance it is reversible but you're
gonna they're gonna have to stay on the
gluten-free diet none of the bad foods
and the ninety cents of nutrients plus
all the secret sauces for life this is
ninety for life not until they feel
better